yet another police shooting of an
unarmed black man took place in Ferguson
Missouri on August 9th Michael Brown was
only 18 it's sadly nothing new and
neither is the portrayal of Brown which
has gotten a ton of backlash on social
media
soon after Brown's death the hashtag if
they gun me down went viral with folks
slamming the mainstream media
stereotypical and predictable portrayal
of him the hashtag is a critique of this
photo of Brown the media used when
telling the story the photo lets some
people online to baselessly believe
Browns peace sign was actually a gang
sign in response tweets pointed out that
other photos of the teen could have been
used that don't perpetuate a negative
stereotype like this recent one black
folks on Twitter also posted their own
side by side photos asking which one the
media would run with if they were quote
gunned down
but just as this isn't the first killing
of an unarmed black person it's also not
the first time people have condemned the
biased portrayals of the victims that
follow a few other hashtags have trended
in 2014 alone nineteen-year-old Renisha
McBride was shot and killed by a
Michigan man when she knocked on his
door her family says she was looking for
help after crashing her car following
Batman's guilty verdict on August 7th
The Associated Press tweeted the
headline suburban Detroit homeowner
convicted of second degree murder for
killing woman who showed up drunk on
porch
hashtag AP headlines trended soon after
with people tweeting ridiculous slanted
imaginary headlines they thought the AP
would use heel on James tweeted breaking
woman violently beats police officers
fists with her face
Cesar Manuel brought it back to racism
schrutes tweeting families bored wrong
ship end up in wrong place with a
picture of a slave ship another hashtag
dangerous black kids erupted on social
after a Florida man killed unarmed 17
year old Jordan Davis following an
argument about loud music a jury
couldn't unanimously agree on a
first-degree murder charge for that man
Michael Dunn the hashtag ridiculed
Dunn's self-defense argument
highlighting the idea that doing
anything while being black is a
perceived threat as maluf tweeted
officer we've got to keep an eye on
these two they're wearing blue and
Mariah Williams said these three are
categorized as little thugs since
they're throwing up the number one this
father posted a vine of his baby
vandalizing his room you got caught you
forgot some pick them up all these
hashtags show that sometimes the only
way to change a biased narrative is to
take control of it so are you fed up
check out some of these other hashtags
and let us know by tweeting us at aj+